a little bit about myself I'm Moloch on
Twitter I'm 18 I'm a student from the
Bay Area and I really like locks and
computers lately I've been getting
really interested in duplicating
high-security keys this is my second
time going to Def Con and my first time
speaking and if you're working on any
interesting lock projects come say hi
I'd love to hear about them
so you've probably seen these things
before there's a good chance you even
live or work in a building that has one
and these boxes contain the keys to the
building so when the firefighters show
up in an emergency they don't have to
start breaking stuff to get where they
need to be they can just open the box
get the keys and let themselves in a
low-tech way of doing this would be to
just keep copies of everyone's keys in
the fire station but having a single key
for an entire area saves a lot of time
in an emergency the most popular rapid
entry system is made by Knox and the
Knox box is mostly what I'll focus on
today and a lot of places these things
are required by law on commercial
buildings so you can have the best high
security locks in the world on your
doors but you still have to put your
keys in this metal box so the
firefighters can get in sometimes these
things even have alarm codes in them
they make really big ones for commercial
buildings and tiny ones for people's
houses again same idea you put your keys
in the box and the firefighters can open
the box they also make padlocks and key
switches for overriding gates and even
boxes with circuit breakers inside and
all of these devices take the same keys
which are held by the local fire
department sometimes one fire department
will get their own unique Knox key and
sometimes many departments will share
the same system sometimes even an entire
state will use a single Knox key
throughout so this is basically a
physical backdoor to an entire city or
even state Bruce Schneier referred to it
as physical key escrow and as I'm sure
you all know by now key escrow isn't
really that great for security these are
pretty powerful keys and as you can
probably imagine it's kind of bad when
they fall into the wrong hands here's
some footage from a burglary in Seattle
this guy walks up and starts messing
with something on the wall and then he
comes back with someone else and enters
a code into their keypad that was
supposed to be reserved for the fire
department and they opened the door go
in the building and leave with some
package
is that they were not supposed to leave
with Seattle then spent half a million
dollars to rekey their NOx boxes
something similar happened in Austin
someone used an ox key to break into a
Children's Hospital and steal $31,000
Austin then spent $300,000 to rekey
their Knox boxes and one and a half
million to make sure it never happened
again they also didn't know how many
Knox boxes they had in their city but
they thought it was around six thousand
also Knox's website seems to be claiming
that only the fire departments have
these keys they've got some videos on
their website where people say things
like only the fire department has access
to that box or only we have a key to
open it and I'm just not sure if that's
100% accurate I mean this Phoenix Fire
Department somehow managed to lose 850
of these keys and they didn't even
notice until they counted them after
hearing about the burglaries in Seattle
so who knows where they are people can
also get in a lot of trouble for
refusing to install these things there
was an article last year about a butcher
from Pennsylvania who didn't want to
install an ox box because he didn't like
the idea of giving strangers access to
his keys the city threatened to put him
in jail for 30 days find him a thousand
dollars and condemn his building as a
fire hazard so if people are going to be
forced to use these I think they have a
right to know what's inside of them a
couple years ago I got in touch with
Knox to ask about the locks they were
using and they pretty much told me to
pounce and they did not want to talk to
me at all so Knox bucks is almost
exclusively used medico 72 series cam
locks older ones use the biaxial and
newer ones use the m3 these are really
cool locks that work a little bit
differently than what most people are
used to I don't really have time to go
into exactly how they work but basically
the cuts on the key can have different
angles as well as depths with a normal
key the only thing that really matters
is how deep the cuts are but with
medicos the angle of the cuts is also
important the key rotates the pins as
well as lifting them up so if you look
at a Medeco key from the top down you
can see that some of the cuts have been
twisted one way and some have been
twisted the other they also don't have
any driver pins
this is what the key pins look like and
I think it's a very clever design these
things are physically very tough and the
lock is super hard to pick it's rated by
you well to withstand many different
types of attacks for thirty minutes I
only know a handful of people who can
pick these things but unfortunately I
don't think they offer enough protection
against unauthorized replication of keys
Knox is pretty serious about key control
the keys are supposed to be kept inside
these electronic boxes which I'm sure
are completely unhackable they're also
connected to radio and Wi-Fi sometimes
which is great but the firefighter has
to enter a pin in order to remove the
key and it keeps track of when that
happens so these keys are pretty well
protected but even if someone has
physical access to a key for just a few
seconds they can still gain a lot of
useful information about it someone
could make measurements of it by taking
a clay impression or by using a key
decoder or just a photograph you don't
even need a good photo in 2008 some
students at UC San Diego showed that
they were able to copy a key that was
photographed from around 200 feet away
and sometimes it's not even necessary to
take your own photo after about 10
minutes of searching on YouTube I found
several videos of people showing off
Knox keys it's probably not good that
these keys are being posted to the
Internet a key is pretty much just a
metal password anyone who can read it
can copy it that being said it's not
always easy to replicate a Medeco key
you wouldn't just be able to get one
copied at the hardware store because
they use special restricted key blanks
and only certain people are allowed to
make copies but these keys are just
chunks of metal and with the right tools
any chunk of metal can be reproduced if
you already have the blank you can make
the cuts on certain key machines or even
just by hand with a metal file but
getting restricted key blanks can be
kind of tricky there are plenty of ways
to make key blanks though for example
modifying another similar blank until it
fits into the lock and there have been
some attacks presented at Def Con before
in some situations you can make a key
blank out of a thin piece of metal or
plastic like a credit card this will
work if the keyway is wide open
but not
so much on the more para centric key
ways if you want to make a better blank
milling is a pretty good way to go
CNC is good there are also Mills built
specifically for duplicating key blanks
but they are very expensive and have
some drawbacks if you don't have access
to one a good 3d printer will work to
cheap FDM printers are usually precise
enough to duplicate something like a
house key pretty easily but with higher
security locks sometimes you need more
precision to make a reliable key SLA
printers are really good for this and
Shapeways has some extremely precise
materials Shapeways is a service that
will 3d print things for you you just
upload your file choose your printer pay
a couple bucks and they mail it to you
I've tested most of their materials and
I like their mjf process the best so
I've been wondering how hard it would be
to print one of these keys from scratch
it turns out it's really not that
difficult the printing is pretty easy
but the real fun begins when you start
trying to model the key obviously I
don't have access to the original key to
begin with and I can't easily get a hold
of one I mean all things considered I
think Knox is doing a pretty good job of
key control they're using
patent-protected keys that are slightly
harder to duplicate the normal keys and
the keys are kept in special boxes and
obviously they won't just sell you the
key but what they will sell you is the
box and the interesting thing is the
lock in the box contains all the
information necessary to reproduce the
key the lock and the key are pretty much
mirror images of each other I mean it
has to be this way because the lock has
to somehow check if the key is correct
there's no encryption no challenge
response just some pieces of metal
interacting with each other and they'll
sell one to anyone who wants to put one
on their building so I bought one to
check it out it came with some cool
documents which I immediately ignored
and sure enough it shipped with the lock
installed these things also ship open so
it's really easy to just unscrew the
thing and pop the lock out
[Applause]
so now I have the Knox lock for my city
and that means I effect idli have a
negative image of the Knox key for my
city and so does everyone else who has
one of these boxes if I can make a key
to open my box then I would have a key
to almost every commercial building in
my city I didn't really want to mess
with mine so I bought some very similar
locks on ebay and started trying to make
a model in open s CAD it's a 3d modeling
tool where you define your shape in a
language similar to C but instead of
compiling into a computer program it
compiles into a shape and since it's
completely parametric it's perfect for
modeling things like keys once you have
your model setup if you want to change
something it's as simple as just
updating some numbers and recompiling
I'm not the first one to use it to model
keys near Patel christian Haller and
Eric van Albert have done that before
but I wanted to try making my own tool
that suited my needs a little bit better
so one of the first challenges I ran
into was modeling the keyway sometimes
medico will remove a lot of metal from
the face of the plug and this makes it
kind of hard to get a good image of the
keyway like if I try to scan or
photograph it the wording is really hard
to see because it doesn't start until
about a few millimeters back from the
face but a quick and dirty way around
that is to just slice the plug in half
and look at a cross-section of it you
can just cut it with a hacksaw or
something it doesn't really matter if it
leaves a nasty rough edge because you
can just lap the face until it's
perfectly even and then if you polish it
and put it down on a flatbed scanner you
should get a pretty crisp image of the
keyway the next thing to consider is
that this cross-section is not perfectly
circular we're taking a cross-section of
a cylinder and if the face we're
scanning is not absolutely parallel with
the front and back of the plug the
picture we'll get will be slightly
elliptical this is pretty easy to
correct for though I made a program that
just transforms the ellipse back into a
perfect circle and then once we have the
image we can bring it into Inkscape
trace it and we have our profile and
then if we extrude that profile we have
a blank then also if you didn't thin the
profile down at all when you traced it
it probably won't quite
into the lock maybe it wasn't traced
properly or the image wasn't completely
accurate or the printer wasn't
calibrated properly so I recommend
thinning the blanket down a little bit
to give it some room you could just try
to eyeball it but I made a program that
lets you print a bunch of keys all stuck
together like this and it smoothly
changes the parameters from one side to
the other so you can start it out thick
on one side and have it get thinner
towards the other and then just snap
them apart to see which one works the
best and then to model the cuts we can
just take the pins out and measure them
the key pins are kind of hard to measure
because they all have the same height so
I recommend making a 3d printed
measurement tool I'll open-source mine
when I'm done with it
and you don't have to be super precise
when measuring the pins because you can
just compare your measurement to the
closest one published by medico also the
only difference between a biaxial key
and an m3 key is this groove that's been
cut out of it so the key can interact
with the m3 slider element this element
is protected under patent but it would
be trivially easy to print a key with a
similar cutout this element does give
the key some legal protection against
duplication but it provides almost zero
technical protection and people have
attacked this element at DEFCON before
it was shown to be very secure as long
as the attacker doesn't have access to a
paper clip or something similar so after
some tweaking and trial and error I was
able to make a working medico key here's
turn is sticking out and it won't go I
didn't unless the correct key is in the
lock and here it is with the correct key
it's a little yeah so that really wasn't
all that hard the process would be
exactly the same to produce the Knox key
to my city this means anyone who has
access to one of these locks and a good
3d printer could produce one of these
keys also if someone really wanted to
get a hold of one of these locks
they wouldn't even need to buy one when
these things are properly installed
they're really tough to remove if you
don't have the key like good luck
getting that thing off but they're not
always properly installed
here's a Knox box on a chain-link fence
so anyone with some wire cutters could
take that thing let's see it would also
probably be pretty easy to take one of
the padlocks if someone has some bolt
cutters or lock picks it would be pretty
hard to pick the Knox padlock but what
about that other lock what if someone
just left one open that lock is
available to anyone who has access to a
wrench or a pair of pliers I took this
photo about eight months ago and it's
still like this today I'm also releasing
the program I made for this it's on
github right now the repository is
called gate keeper it's a couple hundred
lines of open s CAD code designed to
help make keys for locks without
requiring access to the original key to
begin with it's not necessarily for
médicos but it can reproduce all of the
elements of a biaxial key unfortunately
I'm not releasing a version which can do
this cut out for the m3 slider because
that's still under patent and I'm not
entirely sure if it would be that what I
do that but someone could modify this
program to include that feature so check
it out if you're interested but please
don't mess with locks that aren't yours
I'm not talking about this because I
want people to start breaking into
buildings I'm just trying to show that
these things are a security risk so I'm
also not trying to talk trash about
medico
I think the m3 is a very nice lock I
just don't think it should be used for
this application so how could we improve
these knocks could try switching to a
different mechanical lock but then P
like me would just do the same thing to
that one there are some keys which are a
real pain in the ass to duplicate like
the multi lock interactive or the AVA
mcs but you're never going to stop
people from recreating chunks of metal I
think the best way to avoid this kind of
attack would be to avoid key escrow
altogether I think the biggest flaw in
the NOC system is that all of the locks
in each area are identical I can reverse
engineer my Knox box and gain useful
information about my neighbors Knox box
or the hospital down the street or the
bank things might be more secure if we
switched over to electromechanical locks
because electronics let you make it very
difficult to extract secret information
since you have challenge-response and
all that fun stuff it took years for the
DES fire evreyone chip to get broken by
a differential power analysis attack and
that's a lot longer than it took me to
make a Medeco key but the most secure
way to do this will be not to store any
secret information in the lock
each lock could have its own unique
credential that way if I reverse
engineer my lock I would have no useful
information about my neighbors
credential and I think that's how it
should be and it would be much harder to
do stuff like this there's a very neat
combination lock called the rks which is
like a very tiny safe lock that's dialed
with a robotic key if they use something
like this each building could have its
own unique combination and they could
just load them onto the key when they
need to Knox also recently announced an
electronic version of their product
coincidentally they released the
promotional video for it last week it's
a completely electronic system kind of
like the Medeco XT I don't know how
they're doing the electronics but they
say the key can hold a hundred codes
that's not very many so it leads me to
believe that they're not doing away with
key escrow altogether
just making it electronic so you're
probably wondering what if someone hacks
the electronics wouldn't that be really
bad well don't worry according to Knox
it cannot be hacked
they say it is a completely hack proof
system they also say that it can't be
hacked via RF or Bluetooth which kind of
makes sense given the fact that it
doesn't use either of those things but
until we do get these 100% hack proof
locks
what can building owners do to mitigate
key duplication attacks Knox does offer
to sell them with a tamper alert which
is nice it's got two buttons one is to
detect the Box coming off of the wall
and the other is to detect the door
being opened you hook them up to your
burglar alarm so it can go off if
someone messes with the box this is a
nice feature but it's almost never
hooked up pretty much nobody uses these
things they probably should though the
tamper alert seems to be pretty well
designed but on the residential 3200
model Knox was kind enough to include a
drain hole on the bottom this allows me
to just hold that button down with a
bent piece of wire and defeat the tamper
alert here's what that looks like from
the inside there's the button and I go
in and grab it and I can open the door
and the button stays down and if I let
go it pops back up Knox's website says
that the tamper alert provides highest
security and I really hope this isn't
the best they can do so if you are using
that switch maybe don't get one with an
exposed drain hole also have cameras
pointed at the box don't rely completely
on locks for your security get an alarm
and maybe don't put your alarm code in
the box I know you're supposed to but if
your building is on fire or something I
guess it's not a huge deal if your
burglar alarm goes off and as for
long-term solutions I think we should be
switching over to a system where this is
just intrinsically not an issue I'm not
saying this is a huge issue but just
that we can do better going forward if
you're interested check out the github
page for helpful resources and the
programs I used also huge thanks to the
Electronic Frontier Foundation for
answering some of my questions about
this please donate go donate to them and
thank you for listening I hope you found
this interesting
[Applause]